what's happened to reject nation Greg
outta here and John Humphrey over it was
announced today good morning this
morning from the woman herself I'm a
Laker TISS Laurie Strode will be
returning to the Halloween sequel boot
melodium relaunch but ending the series
thing is about to become some people are
saying that it's gonna be the last
Halloween yeah okay we've heard that
yeah there's like eight Halloween movies
in a row now
I think it's oom in every slasher ever
Preiser says it's the end the last one a
new blood only came out a year after the
final chapter in the fat of the 13th
franchise I feel like ending a series
just means you're gonna you know take a
minute and figure out how to continue it
Jamie Lee Curtis posted this morning
it's the same porch same clothes same
issues forty years later headed back to
Haddonfield one last time for Halloween
release date 10 19 18 see because Jamie
Lee Curtis is so much older now I can't
believe this will be her one last time
what I really like about the Halloween
franchise specifically is that the
Strode bloodline is a very consistent
thing throughout yes exploding like one
or two sure part three yeah there's that
whole thing with like Danielle Harris's
character she's like kind of related
some other season the bloodline you know
yeah yeah there's and then they go into
that whole voodoo man and black thing
yeah but I wasn't as big of a fan of in
terms of this happening I think it's
cool because you know Jamie Lee Curtis
it was on scream queens I heard she's
pretty damn good in that show but I was
like yeah Jim Lee curse does like scream
queen it's so cool that she's in the
scream queen show so for her to be
returning to this especially since it's
supposed to be a continuation I thought
this was gonna be just a direct reboot
with John Carpenter involved since we
already got a rebooted Rob Zombie's
movie yeah but those are just like that
you know the side comic book tales we
put to the side I guess while they take
it back up where we
left off from Halloween - my question is
how how do they expect audiences like
we're california-based for la base where
movies are constantly being made and
talked about everyone's in the know when
it comes to movie knowledge and I feel
like other parts of the world and
America a lot of people don't know these
things and this is more confusing than
rebooting spider-man a bunch of times
now like the mystery but at the same
time I'm like there only so many things
it could be and yeah I've kind of ruled
them all out but not it still leaves me
in a place where I'm eagerly
anticipating whatever it is they're
gonna come up with and there's something
again I'm always trepidatious when
directors endorse reboots and things
like that but John Carpenter's said that
Danny McBride and then David Gordon
Green blew him away with their idea and
he said they seemed to really get it so
hey hey we also passed the torch to Rob
Zombie then took back his words on that
when they talked about that he was like
yeah he called him up and he said yeah I
was like sure whatever to do it those
movies never got the blessing the same
way but I don't know I feel like LEM
House has this unique neck right now
whereas if anybody can do it they can
you know of course John Carpenter on is
the executive producer creative
consultant having Blum House behind it
and now having Jamie Lee Curtis like I'm
really worried but at the same time I
think it could work and I think my side
is worried and excited yeah yeah yeah
simultaneously worried because I could
see how it could go wrong excited cuz I
can see how this could be a really fun
time and it could be special because
especially it would be because it's you
know it's not often it's not all the
time that you get now the originator of
the thing to come back and like hey that
worked for Wes Craven a new nightmare
oh he didn't - right new nightmare
didn't he I thought that was what I'm
playing Parker's not directing this new
one nobody's produce but even so coming
back in a big way to the franchise that
you created in my soul mental like
creative involvement kind of well sure
but I still think it'll be more David
Gordon Green's take on this and Danny
McBride's take more than it would be
John Carpenter jiz giving a blessing all
the time on whatever decisions they're
maintaining that but it's I really feel
like it'll be more of a John Carpenter
well that's the thing I'm curious about
too is what his level of involvement is
because it seemed like he was gonna be
involved yeah and he was talking about
possibly doing the music for it yeah
I'm sure you know is his baby and he
seemed to actually throw in like he
showed up for this yeah like the Rob
Zombie one he writes money yeah let Tom
be his thing but this one he's actually
here for well I think what people are
getting really confused by especially
from actual followers of the Halloween
franchise Jamie Lee Curtis is Laurie
Strode supposedly dies in Halloween
resurrection well based off how she died
there I could see her coming back
actually I mean Michael Myers comes back
all the time runs in the family you know
it sure it could happen but then there's
like clarification out there forgot who
said it but someone said that this is
supposed to take place after Halloween -
kind of like when Bryan Singer made
Superman Returns which takes place after
Superman - this is gonna almost be a
hypothetical what if we didn't stray
look we didn't do 9 more movies whatever
we didn't hyper deviate and then go
right back you know and I think what
makes it confusing for audiences to
latch onto they gotta do something at
the beginning of the movie that makes it
crystal clear that the other ones don't
count if this is what they're doing
Jamie Lee Curtis returns in a couple of
Halloween movies down the road you know
it makes it really confusing if they do
Syria they have to make it clear a cut
in the beginning that this is taking
place after Halloween - and the other
ones don't count well otherwise it's
gonna be very confusing where that's
gonna be what they mean by that - yeah
because she's there's no denying she is
aged since Halloween - yeah so you can't
just pick up like right there yeah I
think they're gonna spend the money to
DHR the entire film you know and and I
don't know again what involvement Laurie
Strode yeah that's gonna be a cameo is
gonna be a scene is it gonna be a full
supporting characters in the lead
character we're not entirely sure what
its gonna be but regardless you know
Jamie Lee Curtis won the ultimate scream
queen she was the star of the first two
Halloween's which are arguably the best
ones I like Halloween for a lot yeah
personally I think called me for is
pretty good I could see this going wrong
at the same time though I am excited
they're bringing her back Laurie Strode
is such an integral character of the
Halloween franchise and she's Laura
shrug characters in the Halloween
reboots that Rob Zombie did but it's
nothing like the Jamie Curtis care yeah
wholly different universe what's gonna
be fascinating to me about this
experience is you've seen Laurie Strode
on Halloween one and two and then you
see her down the road many years later
and h2o and resurrection then she had a
specific take on Laurie Strode many
years later after the events of Michael
Myers it was a very specific take on it
and now she's gonna have to disregard
all that and do another specific tape
but many years later even later down the
road without all the events of h2o
resurrection happening I'm really
curious to see what they're gonna do
whether a character are they gonna do
something very different and more
rewarding for fans I hope so man because
like we've had a couple wrap ups now
yeah we're getting somehow we're getting
a third chance at this you know like our
she's back and she might actually put it
into this and they they're billing this
is perhaps the final Halloween like we
saw how much bike about any franchise
especially these horror movie franchises
I feel like it could be if it's good
good they might be able to actually
leave this one alone at least for awhile
yeah yeah why would you even jigsaws
coming back it doesn't seem like they're
rebooting saw so like in terms of
remaking the first films yeah there's
always something you can do but it would
be nice to have one of these guys just
cap it off yeah you know at least for
now I think she should just do True Lies
to campaign for that baby you know that
degraded again yeah all right well guys
are you excited for the new Halloween
reboot sequel finale thingy they're
doing and the Halloween is singing
are you excited for Laurie Strode to
come back yeah what are you guys
thoughts on this you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell follow - on Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram you know we do that how it
could work for Friday the 13th
like we pitched our whole ideas like 20
something minute video yeah people
really responded positively to that and
I've been contemplating should we do
nine realms for Halloween I'm thinking
like maybe we could tackle like a howl
away with all the information they gave
us yeah with this information how do we
put it together yeah a good way oh man
we'd have to have to do is watch the
first two I don't also check out our
patreon become a patreon dejected a
people having a lot of fun over there
jump on it